you know i also like kind of the
downhill delivery he's a tall guy who
uses his height
liner and caught down at third by tommy
edmond they're all off to slow starts
statistically but they all have high
ceilings
you're trying to cut score on a ball
hitting the outfield you're throwing out
that's one thing but don't run into it
now
there's o'neill
backing up a step or two to make the
catch oviedo a one two three footy ponce
been wayne his whole life for this his
first major league start
[Applause]
there's one
and two
around the horn riddle
frazier to bell
that's not a pun
what was it
they're describing the pitch
ball left and reynolds makes the catch
oh oh down here yeah
headed up the middle but there's a man
there and it turns into a double play so
if you
are hitting that ball you're dylan
carlson maybe you're thinking as it
first starts out it's gonna be an rbi
single
and bouncer to
second cody ponce well done riddle goes
to third murphy down to second base
and into left field as the infield was
drawn in the pirates take a one-nothing
lead
here's the pitch and swing of the ball
looped out to center drops down for a
base hit murphy's in to score gonzalez
puts on the break she'll head to second
on the rbi single by adam frazier the
pirates lead two to nothing
right side open except for bell
45 feet off the line another fastball
cut on and missed above the zone ponce
has his first strikeout tonight
like the aggressiveness
[Applause]
pop up can somebody get there
osuna and they let it drop
trying to get the man at second and what
a pick by gonzalez on the other end
like a first baseman the stretch
and a two-nothing pirates lead
and a pop up to left
reynolds
one out
lion drive and look at gonzalez he can
play some defense
we are going to grind you out even if
we're not scoring a lot of runs you're
going to leave feeling like you pitched
a whole game and danny colton says
everyone in the lineup has the kind of
ability to put together an at-bat would
have seven runs of their own
that'll carry to dylan carlson he'll
make the catch and the town number two
good breaking ball and he will finish at
least this inning shift on the right
side and carlson yanks it down the right
field line and that is a
fair ball into the corner
and dylan has himself a double to lead
things off here in inning number five
good start
popped it up
[Music]
riddle
calls off murphy with one out here's the
one one and a swing and a pop-up
out towards first base bell
calling off frazier he makes the catch
that's the second out
a lead-off double still standing at
second
curious how long they'll let box go kind
of miss on that curve and they'll throw
on the first to complete the strikeout
so
cody ponce
five scoreless innings
in his first major league start the
chevy line on
gomber
and a fly ball to carlson and the catch
he's made
[Applause]
lifted in the air
shallow right carlson coming on and
he'll make the catch
there's a curveball chopped on the
ground right side and
the pirate swirl strand a pair
ponce in his first major league start
but he's pitch while yeah he's throwing
up zeroes
bounce toward third
and two outs
[Applause]
and what can you say about what you're
seeing from cody ponce
and a fly ball lifted out to deep center
field at the wall it's off the top of
the wall
tucker fell down miller
on his way to third
and in there safely
now derek shelton has to be extremely
pleased with the understatement of the
year baby what a job a couple punches to
the chest five and two thirds five hits
no runs couple of walks a couple of
strikeouts breaking ball swung on popped
up again right side bell and foul ground
with room
makes the catch hartley strands another
signed by the giants as a minor league
free agent he was almost exclusively a
starting pitcher
in the right
pretty deep and tucker
well got both feet in
how about that
nick turley strikes out dylan carlson
hop up
right field osuna coming on and for the
second time today raise
the jolly roger cody ponce
his first
big league start gets his first major
league win